thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video let me start by
saying that generally individuals don't
matter in the history of science the
history of science is a history of big
social and economic and technological
factors though of course sometimes an
individual does arise out of that big
picture people like einstein james clerk
maxwell but those individuals normally
follow a pattern they're from a wealthy
background their family normally has
some kind of training in or connection
to science fairy tale rags to riches
stories just don't exist except of
course sometimes
very rarely
they do
like the janitor turned international
scientist
james kroll
but before telling you his story let me
set the scene it's the 19th century
science as we know it is in the process
of being born in particular scientists
are starting to realize that our planet
looked very different in the past
geologists are uncovering evidence that
snow and ice had previously thousands of
years ago covered all of europe in what
was being called the ice age at the time
the scientific consensus was that the
earth was still gradually cooling from
its formation so this idea of the earth
being colder in the past was quite
revolutionary the question of how the
earth could have a period of intense
cold in its deep past was an open one it
was largely investigated at institutions
like universities and scientific
societies like the royal society in
london these institutions often trace
back their roots for hundreds of years
but it was really in the 19th century
that they became the place to do
research that meant that if you couldn't
get access to one of these institutions
then you were largely shut out from
cutting-edge research one such
institution was the andesonian
university in glasgow which is now part
of strathclyde university in 1859 it got
a new janitor
james kroll was born in 1821 to a very
poor crofting family in perthshire in
scotland and he was born with the front
part of his skull not properly formed
and he'd be plagued by this disability
and general ill health for his entire
life when he was old enough to go to
school he actually refused to go
initially because he was worried that
the other children would laugh at him
for the unusual shape of his head he
didn't go for several years and when he
eventually did go and hated it it was
only a couple of years before the family
called him back to work on the farm
because they were struggling to make
ends meet all this is to say that he
ended up being largely self-educated and
in particular a magazine namely the
penny magazine of the society for the
diffusion of useful knowledge
wow sparked an interesting crowl in
science unfortunately though there was
no way for krell to follow up on this
interest because he was very poor and
there were no opportunities for very
poor people to get further education
but
his meager source of income the family
farm eventually became unsustainable and
he had to leave to get another job and
for several years kroll scraped by
working whatever job he could he was a
joiner he worked on a newspaper he sold
insurance he ran a hotel but in all of
these things he was incredibly unlucky
things just kept happening to him that
meant he had to leave his jobs often it
was his physical health that would just
fail him and he'd have to leave and find
something new by 1859 kroll is nearly 40
he's desperately poor he's struggling to
feed himself and now he's a wife and
he's constantly unwell he's physically
frail having been kicked from job to job
to job he has this dream of following
science but
no way to make that dream a reality but
he gets the break of a lifetime when he
lands a job as a janitor he's paid one
pound a week to clean the library at the
andersonian university well actually him
and his brother are paid to clean the
library and it's unclear how much of the
cleaning james actually did because
inspired by years of reading the penny
magazine kroll took this opportunity to
devour the contents of the library he
taught himself the latest theories in
mathematics and physics and geology and
astronomy and eventually started
corresponding with the authors of those
theories not fan mail but critiquing
their work and he engaged in a level
playing field intellectual debate with
people like charles darwin and lord
kelvin and john tyndall and it became
clear that all along cross had this
unbelievable mind the thing that he
seemed particularly interested in though
was the cause of this newly discovered
ice age and he thought presumably while
sweeping the floor or cleaning windows
that the french mathematician josef
ademar was on the right lines when he
suggested that variations in the earth's
orbit around the sun were responsible
for the ice age because the earth's
orbit isn't exactly circular it's
elliptical or a squashed circle you may
recall that the earth is also tilted in
its orbit meaning that one hemisphere is
more exposed to the sun for half the
year than the other causing the seasons
now adama argued that if the northern
hemisphere's summer corresponded with
when the earth was closest in its
elliptical orbit to the sun its summer
would be particularly hot and its winter
particularly cold and vice versa the
southern hemisphere summer would be
colder and it's winter warmer as the
earth goes around the sun over and over
again though the direction its axis
points in changes very slowly and
eventually those rolls will be flipped
with the southern hemisphere having
hotter summers and colder winters it's
summer lining up with the closest
approach of the earth to the sun and of
course the opposite for the northern
hemisphere this changing of roles
happens on a regular cycle that's tens
of thousands of years long and it's also
moderated and varied by several other
complicated bits of orbital mechanics
kroll hypothesized that this orbital
variation was responsible for the ice
age he claimed that when a hemisphere's
winter was particularly cold more snow
would fall and so over hundreds and
thousands of years that snow would be
compacted into ice sheets that would
cover the landscape an ice age crucially
he also realized that the more snow that
falls on the ground and the more ice
that forms in the sea the more
reflective the earth becomes reducing
the amount of energy that it absorbs
from the sun
cooling it even further cooling an
already cooler earth that would then
lead to more snow that would then lead
to more reflection and even more cooling
and so on what we would today call a
positive ice albedo feedback loop so
those orbital variations didn't even
need to be that big in order to produce
huge changes in climate enough to cause
ice ages yes ice age is plural krell
figured that this was a regular cycle
and so it would cause regular ice ages
despite the fact there was no evidence
at that time for that being the case but
he trusted his mats this theory was
fantastic it was truly brilliant and
kroll was acclaimed by the great
scientists of his day people like darwin
but unfortunately
there was no way to know if he was right
or not the experimental techniques to
prove or disprove his theories hadn't
even been imagined yet regardless kroll
was given an official academic post
allowing him to hang up his broom and
for the first time in his life
he was able to live
comfortably because
he'd made it he'd made it to the inner
echelons of science to one of these
institutions where research was done and
he was accepted and respected by his
peers but sadly this wasn't to last
after a brief hard-won career in
academia kroll's health failed him again
and he felt compelled to resign and in
fact retire
in poverty once more until his death
and while he was lauded in his lifetime
within a few decades of his death he'd
been mostly forgotten
as had his theory in fact the few
academics who did remember the theory
basically dismissed it out of hand
until a far most famous name in this
field came along
the serbian militant milankovic
milankovic extended kroll's mathematics
and corrected a mistake in them because
it's actually summers being colder when
the summer hemisphere is further from
the sun that prevents ice melt that
leads to an ice age not winters being
even colder and because of these
developments the theory became known as
milankovitch cycles and when eventually
in the 1970s techniques were invented
that could establish past temperatures
from ocean sediment cores it was
milankovich's theory that was proven
correct his mathematics neatly lined up
with a bunch of ice ages throughout
earth's history
and so it's his name not unjustly that
was associated with this theory the
variations in the earth's orbit around
the sun forced its climate but perhaps
we should be calling them kroll
milankovitch cycles because james kroll
laid the foundations of the theory and
he made the crucial realization that
feedback loops on earth would amplify
any forcing from orbital variations his
genius was recognized in his lifetime
one obituary claimed every honest
scientific investigator will admit that
kroll's writings have had the most
radical influence on cosmological
speculation in certain directions his
influence has been nearly as great as
that of darwin's in biology none of this
is to take away from milankovitch's work
which was also brilliant all i'm saying
is that i think james kroll should be
better known he's one of the thousands
of men and women throughout history who
were links in the chain of scientific
knowledge but weren't the last link and
so
just haven't been remembered he overcame
incredible odds and swam against the
tides of economics and social mobility
of the time to become one of these
remarkable men one of these incredible
stories a fairy tale in the history of
science may i present to you possibly
the greatest janitor the world has ever
known
james kroll
remember him
the story of the earth is a dramatic one
it's a story of ice and fire and
collisions and creation and destruction
the very ground beneath my feet right
now is only here because of hundreds of
millions of years of violence it's a
story told in 300 million years actually
it's more like an hour and a half a
documentary on the formation of the
continent of europe one of the thousands
of documentaries on curiosity stream if
you fancy expanding your horizons with
expertly crafted and curated
documentaries on your lunch breaks or in
the evenings curiosity stream is perfect
for you rather than re-watching friends
again why not learn about kurdistan or
african art or coffee or bees or perhaps
you prefer something indie like this
video perhaps you'd like to watch more
videos like this without any adverts in
them at all from a variety of
educational content creators perhaps
you'd even like to watch exclusive
content like lindsey ellis analyzing how
tropic thunder changed hollywood well
you're in luck because that's nebula the
thoughtful educational streaming
platform that's partnered up with
curiosity stream if you go to
curiositystream.com simon clark you get
access to the best of both worlds the
high production value documentaries on
curiosity stream and the indie videos on
nebula and better yet with this bundle
you get a 26 discount on a subscription
to curiosity stream less than 15 a year
but that's not all with this bundle you
directly support educational creators
like me and you help support the
development of online educational video
by allowing creators like me to take
risks and do things that aren't
necessarily algorithm friendly that's
curiositystream.com simonclark to access
both curiosity stream and nebula and get
that 26 discount thanks to all of you
who have already signed up to this
bundle and thank you to curiositystream
for sponsoring this video
i really hope that you enjoyed this
video i found out about kroll when i was
researching my book you can pre-order it
now link in the description and as soon
as i heard his story i just knew that i
had to make a video about him and his
incredible life story if you'd like to
learn more details about his life then
please do check out this fantastic talk
by mike robinson of the royal scottish
geographical society which goes into way
more detail than i could fit into this
video and it was a really useful
resource for putting together the video
if you'd like to watch some more stuff
by me then here's some recommended doing
next if you did enjoy the video please
do pop it a like and share it with
people that you think might find it
interesting as well thank you for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one